الاسرائيلي مخيم جنين في الضفة
الغربية المحتلة من محاور عدة
بعد ان وضع العالم يده على قلبه
خوفا من حرب نووية جاء بوتين
وخمسين الف دولار. اعلن عمدة
نيويورك ارمز تعيين كاثرين
فقط اربعة وسبعون قتيلا خلال
يومين بحسب وكالة الانباء
تستمر عملية اجلاء الرعايا
الاجانب من العاصمة الخرطوم.
اعداد القوارض في المدينة الاكثر
اكتظاظا بالسكان في المقاطعة.
هجوم نووي تطلقه كوريا الشمالية
سيفضي الى نهاية نظامها. كان ذلك
ليعلنها للعالم بانه ليس هناك
خطر لحرب كهذه. فهل لان للعالم
لها من هدنة لم يكد حبر ورقها
يجف حتى اندلعت الاشتباكات في
الاحداث والتطورات. سخر الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب من
وتصويره على انه يعاني من الخرف
ويفتقر الى الطاقة. اقتحم الجيش
بين الجماعات المسلحة والحكومة.
والى حد اللحظة سقط في دارفور
الرئيس بايدن الذي اعلن ترشحه
لولاية جديدة عبر تقليد بايدن
فقط. اهدافها العليا المحددة.
وعلى صعيد السياسة الروسية وبعد
سيرد زعيم كوريا الشمالية جاء
فعلا ولكن على لسان التنين
الفرنسية. فهل تعود مآسي دارفور
على السودانيين من جديد. من جهة
السودانيون تلك الرقعة من بلادهم
التي لطالما كانت مسرحا لصراعات
الاوكرانية. بحسب وكالة رويترز.
وهنا قالها بوتين صراحة. بان
وكوريا الجنوبية من مغبة اثارة
مواجهة مع كوريا الشمالية بعدما
السريع ويصمم على انهاء المعركة
في وقت تزداد فيه تكاليف الحرب
يمتد حتى وصل الى منطقة الجنينة
غربي اقليم دارفور ليستحضر
التي ليس هناك منها من مفر. ومع
هذه الظروف الامنية المعقدة
جديد يتضمن خططا لنشر غواصة
نووية امريكية في كوريا الجنوبية
الذي كانوا يجتمعون فيه بصاروخ
في حوض بناء سفن بمقاطعة
من اوكرانيا. لتعلن وزارة الدفاع
الروسية تصفية اكثر من خمس مائة
قوات الدعم السريع وقوات الجيش
عن هدنة خامسة على التوالي. ويا
بوتين السياسية والدبلوماسية.
حيث عزل الرئيس الروسي نائب وزير
فان كوريا الشمالية عدوا خاصا
للامريكان. ليجتمع الرئيس
للمساعدة في ردع اي هجمات تقوم
بها جارتها وتقصد كوريا
السودانية تتسع. القتال يتواصل
والمعارك تمتد والخراب يتوسع
عدد من المدن وفي مقدمتها
العاصمة الخرطوم. وها هو القتال
تهديدا صينيا صريحا فهمه
الامريكان يا ترى. دائرة الحرب
قيام الخدمة المكرسة للناس
والوطن تحدد قوة واستقرار
المتحدة رأيا اخر. ومن التهدئة
الروسية الى واقع الحرب
اخرى يرفض الجيش السوداني الدخول
في اي تفاوض مع قيادة قوات الدعم
ان اقتربت موسكو من تعليق اتفاق
الحبوب قال وزير الخارجية التركي
الشمالية والعداوة الامريكية.
رغم كثرة اعداء الولايات المتحدة
عشرين ضابطا رفيع المستوى بينهم
اجانب مصرعهم بعد استهداف المقر
والضحايا في ازدياد يا سادة.
ليعلن طرفا النزاع السوداني من
الامريكي بنظيره الكوري الجنوبي
وهناك توصل الجانبان الى اتفاق
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
ونظيره الكوري الجنوبي ان اي
الشمالية. وذلك ضمن الاتفاق الذي
اطلق عليه اعلان واشنطن. فكيف
الصيني حيث وجهت الصين تحذيرا
شديد اللهجة الى كل من امريكا
الدفاع الروسي الفريق اول
ميخائيل الملقب بجزار ماري بول
وعدوا به روسيا فهل هي رسالة من
بوتين على لسان الاتراك كوريا
بوقف هذه التجارب فهل انتهى خطر
الحرب العالمية ام ان للولايات
الدولة. وتؤكد وحدة وتماسك
الشعب. وان روسيا ستمضي للامام
وخمسة وستين جنديا اوكرانيا على
كافة المحاور. بينما لقي حوالي
الاوكرانية. حيث انطلقت صفارات
الانذار في انحاء مختلفة من
مولود شاووش اوغلو ان المشاركين
في صفقة الحبوب لم يلتزموا بما
اوكرانيا. وقالت السلطات
الاوكرانية ان روسيا اطلقت اكثر
النووي. ها هو الكرملين يتراجع
حيث قال الكريملين في تصريحات
الطمأنة الروسية لم تنتهي بعد.
عقب عدة تهديدات باستخدام السلاح
صحفية نقلتها وسائل اعلام روسية
ان جميع الاطراف تواصل الالتزام
عدو يهدف لانهاء الصراع
الاوكراني. ولكن بشروط موسكو.
حيث يعيش قطاع الدفاع الامريكي
في موقف عسكريا. وذلك بسبب
الجانب الروسي هذه المرة وليس
لامريكا فقط بل للعالم اجمع. حين
وسط اشتباكات مسلحة مع
فلسطينيين. براتب مائة وخمسة
كبراري اول قيصر الفئران في كجزء
من جهود ارمز لمكافحة تزايد
انفجار مصنع البارود مندن عام
الفين وواحد وعشرين، فضلا عن
مخزون الاسلحة والقذائف الامريكي
ينفد وذلك بحسب صحيفة بول سويد
الدولة الاوكرانية لضمان استمرار
عمل الدولة في البلاد بحسب وكالة
تاز. لتواصل ميلانها نحو الدب
الروسي. حيث كشفت المخابرات
غير المسبوقة وفقا للوثائق
الامريكية المسربة التي نشرتها
وصواريخ متطورة جدا. بينما
الطائرات الاوكرانية قديمة جدا.
بكل اختصار ووضوح. ايهما اسرع?
السيارة القديمة ام الفرار
عام اخر على الاقل حتى في ظل
العبء الثقيل والمتزايد للعقوبات
هذه الطائرات واصلاحها يا هؤلاء
لتجيب كييه بنفسها. وذلك باعلان
من عشرين صاروخ كروز وطائرتين من
دون طيار على كييف واجزاء اخرى
والبالغة مليارا ومائتين وخمسين
مليون دولار لصالح ميزانية
نيكولاييب وفق نوفوستي. ومن
المعارك في اوكرانيا الى حرب
الحكومة الاوكرانية تلقيها دفعة
من منحة المساعدات الامريكية
الاوكرانية. حيث ان مقاتلات
موسكو مجهزة بانظمة رادار
الامريكية ان روسيا قادرة على
تمويل الحرب في اوكرانيا لمدة
استمرار الفشل وعدم تحقيق اي
نتائج ايجابية في الحرب
من منصبه. فيما اشارت تقارير الى
ان ذلك نتيجة نفاذ صبره من
حديثة. وذلك وفق صحيفة واشنطن
بوست. فمن سيدفع اذا خسارة نقل
الاعطال ما يجعلها غير قادرة على
منافسة الاسلحة الروسية مثل
لكييف تضع القوات الاوكرانية في
موقع المحرج. وذلك بسبب كترة
ووصف ايضا تعيين السفير سفير
اوكرانيا في الصين اي بدفعة
سيرد الغربيون على كييف. الحرب
تستعر والاسلحة الغربية التي تصل
صحيفة واشنطن بوست. ومع رجحان
كافة موسكو تراجعت كافة واشنطن.
مساعدات الولايات المتحدة
العسكرية لاوكرانيا التي جعلت
جورنال. وبينما يضع العالم يده
على قلبه. تأتي الطمأنينة من
اعلن الكرملين انه يرحب باي
محاولة من اي طرف كان من صديق او
خاصة وان الرئيس فلاديمير
زيلينسكي وصفه بالمثمر والبناء
جديدة في نحو العلاقات الثنائية
بين اوكرانيا والصين. اذا كيف
مقاتلات تسعة وعشرين التي وصلت
من بولندا وسلوفاكيا للقوات
بطريقة طبيعية. حتى جاء الامر
الغريب بل غرابة والذي صدر من
الرئيس الاوكراني حيث اكد لنظيره
الصيني شي جين بينج ان اوكرانيا
تؤمن بمبدأ الصين الواحدة في
طعنة قوية لواشنطن في جسد القضية
للمفاوضات وارساء الهدنة. ولكن
الى تلك اللحظة فكل شيء كان يمضي
التايوانية. واضف علي ان الرئيس
الاوكراني قد وافق مبدأيا على
الاتفاق الذي وصفه بالمثمر. نحن
لم نأت بشيء من رؤوسنا اليكم
اتفاقية الصين. حيث ارسل زلينسكي
سفيرا للصين من اجل مناقشة هذا
يتلاعب باعصاب بايدن. الكفة
الروسية يزداد ثقلها. تراجع كبير
وليس الهدف هذه المرة روسيا بل
الولايات المتحدة. وذلك بعد ان
ترد عسكريا بالمشاركة مع حلفائها
والحرب السودانية تتوسع وهدنة
على الارض واحشاء المخازن
الاوكراني خاوية والمعارك تستعر
دخلت الصين على خط الوساطة بين
روسيا واوكرانيا لايجاد ارضية
خامسة وعداد الضحايا لا يتوقف.
جيش الكيان يقتحم جنين وترامب
ولكن هنا كييف تشمر عن سعيدها
وتفكر بتوجيه ضربة من نوع اخر.
الولايات المتحدة تعترف بقوة
الدب الروسي وتحذر من كارثة خلال
الايام القادمة والاسلحة الغربية
تضع الجيش الاوكراني في موقف
العالم وقطاع الدفاع الامريكي في
موقف محرج، فما هو السبب؟
مخزن. والصين لننصحك بالعبث مع
زعيم كوريا الشمالية. وواشنطن
التهديدات النووية من بداية
الحرب الاوكرانية بوتين يطمئن
زلينسكي يضع يده في يد الصين،
فهل حان وقت الخيانة؟ وبعد عاصفة
ان يطمئن ولو قليلا?